رد روسيا اليوم أن هذه
الدبابات ستحترق مثل كل الدبابات
الأخرى ما هي
رسالتك إلى روسيا اليوم
أثبت الأوكرانيون مهارة فائقة
وقدرة أه في تشغيل أه
المعدات التي قدمها حلفاء وشركاء الناتو وهم
متأكدون تمامًا من أنهم سيفعلون.  قادرون
على القيام بذلك أيضًا مع دبابات قتال رئيسية
من دول حلف شمال الأطلسي خاصة
لأن
العديد منهم لديهم خبرة كبيرة
بالفعل في الخطوط الأمامية أه
تشغيل الدبابات المدرعة من الحقبة السوفيتية
ولكن بالطبع هذه
خلفية مفيدة عندما  ثم ابدأ
التدريب على الدبابات القتالية الحديثة ودبابات الناتو ،
علينا أن نتذكر ما هي هذه
الحرب أو العدوان. الرئيس بوتين
غزو
دولة أخرى مستقلة ذات سيادة في أوروبا.
أه
هذا صحيح
لأنه إذا فاز الرئيس بوتين ، فهذه
مأساة بالنسبة للأوكرانيين ولكنها كلها
خطيرة بالنسبة لنا لأن الرسالة وهي
أنه عندما يستخدم القادة الاستبداديون
القوة العسكرية فإنهم يحصلون على ما يريدون
وبعد ذلك يصبح العالم أكثر
خطورة ونصبح أكثر ضعفاً
وبالتالي  من مصلحتنا الأمنية
دعم الأوكرانيين